hey guys today we're gonna talk about
the health benefits of the avocado okay
this thing is a superfood so let's talk
about it so number one the amount of
nutrients is very very high there's a
lot of potassium an average avocado has
between 500 to 800 or even eight hundred
and fifty milligrams of potassium which
is good for energy good for your blood
Sugar's good for the heart it's also
potassium is a physiological relaxer so
it's gonna help you sleep at night it'll
actually help lower blood pressure it
does a lot it has a full length which is
a B vitamin it's loaded with vitamin C
vitamin K k1 the B vitamins b5 b6
vitamin e b2 like museum manganese zinc
b3 vitamin A in the preform of beta
carotene so it's not actually retinol
but the precursor to retinol but all the
other fats in avocado help this
conversion so it's loaded with fat
soluble vitamins which actually enhance
the absorption of other nutrients okay
number two it's very keto friendly now
what makes things keto is how many
carbohydrates they have so per cup and
avocado has about 12 grams of
carbohydrate but we're gonna take the
net carbs so we're gonna - the fiber
which is 10 grams of fiber per cup
giving us a net carb of 2 grams per cup
so this is an incredibly keto friendly
food 2 grams of carbs for this whole
thing so this should make right around
one cup number three it has high amounts
of fat 77 percent of this is actually
fat mostly mono saturated this could be
very friendly to your lipoproteins and
just so you know when you consume fatty
foods like this you're not gonna gain
fat okay it's not gonna happen alright
number four fiber and I'm gonna have to
kind of explain this a little bit
because all fiber is not the same you
have in Seibel fiber and you have Seibel
fiber okay so let's just talk about it
because the fiber in avocado is mostly
75 percent
in Seibel so I have to explain it so
cyber fiber is fermented for your
microbes your microbes consume it okay
and then they make butyric acid which is
really good for your insulin levels and
your blood sugars and it's food for your
colon cells so soluble fiber gels with
water whereas inside the fiber does not
cyber fiber slows down digestion inside
low fiber speeds up digestion so too
much of it can give you diarrhea too
much cyber fiber can give you
constipation especially if you don't
consume enough water now I notice when I
eat a large salad I get thirsty I need
to drink more water well that is because
your body's telling you we need to add
the water because in the dissolving
process it needs water now anytime
there's fermentation there could be gas
involved and this is why I wanted to
explain this because there are two types
of insoluble fiber
okay there's fermentable so I'm inside
the fiber and non fermenting insoluble
fiber so one type of fermenting inside
the fiber is resistant starch and the
reason I'm bringing this up is because
when you consume in resistant starch
which usually some potatoes it's in the
bananas and it's in some other foods as
well this could give you gas because
it's fermentable by your microbes but of
course if you're in keto you're not
going to be consuming potatoes or
bananas okay so you don't to worry about
that all you need to know is there's
different types of fibers that are
influenced differently by your body and
with avocados it's 75 percent in size
fiber okay the 25 percent can be used
for your bacteria all right lastly
phytonutrients okay this is an
additional health benefit going beyond
these nutrients right here so you have
carotenoids phytosterols oh and by the
way carotenoids being a very powerful
phytonutrient are fat soluble so when
you consume other fats with it you get
better absorption and the benefits of
phytonutrients are anti-inflammatory
anti-cancer antimicrobial and on top of
that they can really support your blood
triggers as well all right guys there
you have it the five health benefits of
an avocado so if you want more knowledge
on how to create a healthy body
subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird
well I'll just remind you on a daily
basis how about that